五块
谁要谁来勾谁要谁来勾
来这个格子格子的
来给朋友们看一下这个衬衫
格子衬衫牌子这个牌
牌子这个牌
来这一款
来格子衬衫有扣有会呀
有扣有会呀
这是一个
开衫
没有标了
没有标了来
胸围的话是106 110
106可以拉伸到110
来长度的话是78
长度78来这个29 29扣8
29 29谁要谁来扣个8
来喜欢的姐姐就扣了29扣8
来来来29扣个8
29扣个8
谁要谁来勾谁要谁来勾
哎呦
29扣8
来这个裙子
威领的一个直筒裙
灰色灰色单层单层
我看它有没有标
35没有标了
没有标了没有标了
后面底边开了个叉
后面底边开叉两边有斜扎口袋
两边有斜扎口袋
但这个有一点瑕疵
有点轻微的色差
有一点轻微的色差
轻微轻微的
来这一款咱们来量一下你们听一下
来胸围胸围
116118116118
来长度长度长度来119长度是群长119
来这一款谁要谁来扣19吧
19扣1
1919谁要谁来扣个1
19扣119扣1
有一点点色差轻微啊不严重
看到了吗
不怎么能看得出来在这个位置
看不pie
看不拍到
看不拍得出
看得出
往我面前面有没有
好来
哎呦哎呦
来
400 400
好 截个图
来 这个紫色的这个裤子
里边感觉有点像毛毛的
有一点点
这个要秋冬穿吧
来 这个腰式半腰松紧的紫色
两边有口袋直等裤
两边有口袋腰式半腰松紧
来 腰围66
可以拉到82
臀围100
可以拉到108
当长35
裤长94
来 这个谁要谁来扣
来 来 来
29 29扣6
来 谁要谁来扣
29扣6
L码来这个蓝白条的
镂空镂空
的这个短款的小外搭
非常好看
镂空的
里边穿个小美味
非常好看
来这一款维的
来胸围
胸围1181122118122
来长度47长度47
来谁要1919扣7扣7
来谁要谁来扣1919扣7扣7
喜欢的姐姐看过19扣7
찰
来这个小脚的哈伦库
哈伦库
免99
拒止1%
36的小马
来我来量一下这个谁要9块
腰围66
可以拉到72
臀围84
可以拉到90
来当场28
当场28
裤长99
来谁要9块9块扣0
9块9块扣0扣0
来喜欢的姐姐就给我
来这一款是迪士尼的
迪士尼联名款啊
这个小外套
来这款是迪士尼联名款
看一下
看到了没有
来
面料嘎嘎好啊
这个款
底边看底边带收的
来这一款啊
它是一个主布棉100
配布棉50
就是拒止49.1
就这样的就是底部
就这种这里啊
它是棉加拒止的
然后身上是全棉的啊
来这个戴帽子
底边可以收
底边可以收来这个外套
这个外套啊
好来这一款咱们来量一下
下摆可以收的啊
它的袖子是有裤有裤呀的
看看有裤有裤呀的
后背是这样戴帽子的
戴帽子的看到了吗
帽子是个薄的
是个薄的
来来来
是的是的
嗯
像这个孔是不错的
不是
不过就是高度状态
像这样子
背包裤子
然后态度是P1
因为它是 ні
那下边先 Risky
下边先elle
还是NP
你是儿子
Jeroy
帽子
你只要坐那么高照片
你就可以唧人家眼睛
響鐘
来这款我来量一下
你们听一下有扣有扣的
底边带收的底边带收的
胸围是102 104 102 104
来腰围的话是92 96 92 96
来长度的话是66长度66
来这一款谁要谁来扣
谁要谁来扣这一款
29 29扣个2
29谁要谁来扣个2
谁要谁来扣个2
来喜欢的姐姐就给我29扣个2
完了完了完了完了完了完了
再来两种
好
这款面料锯纸的
来这个纸桶裤腰是松紧腰
腰是松紧腰
来这款没有口袋
光板光板没有口袋的
来这款咱们来看一下
纸桶的纸桶的面料锯纸
面料锯纸的
来这是一个M码
M码面料锯纸
腰后面带松紧的
来纸桶裤
纸桶裤腰围60
可以拉到86
腿围116
可以拉伸到120
116 120
当场是35
当场35裤长98
来这个裤子谁要39
39扣8扣8
来喜欢的姐姐一股39
扣个8
来这一款来给朋友们看一下
腰是松紧腰
小纸桶小纸桶的
两边有口袋
来腰围64
可以拉到88
臀围96
可以拉伸到100
来当场是36
当场36
裤长100
来这个裤子谁要谁来扣
9块9块
扣0扣0
来喜欢的姐姐去扣个0
哎呀
好感人
要照赶了吗你
哎呦
哎呦妈呀天动
嗯
哎呀
准备下班了啊
快了快了还有三分钟
来这款IOMA的鞋子
L码的单层单层
圆领圆领
前面有扣有扣眼
有一排扣啊
腰上有出绳
面料锯纸
面料锯纸的
来这一款咱们来量一下
胸围胸围
胸围106108
腰围8090
来群长102
群长102
来这款谁要29
谁要谁来扣个2
来喜欢的姐姐就扣
29扣2
等今天等一下我就下播了
明明今天休息
来谁要谁来扣
晚上没人扣了
29扣个2
来这一款
家居群
年35聚值65
圆领腰式松紧腰
腰式松紧腰
对明明今天休息
来胸围胸围
可以拉到116
腰围的话62
可以拉到92
62 92
群长125
怪不得还没见人
对来这一款谁要19
19扣1
1919扣1扣1
来谁要谁来扣19扣1
我儿子没有
我儿子要16号
16号左右才能回来
还没回来了
还没回来吗
儿子还没回来
来这一款来给帮帮看
还能消耗三五六天
回来就得让他写作业
来威领威领
来给帮你看腰式松紧腰
来秀的是个花边袖
来秀的是一个花边袖
花边袖腰式松紧腰
来这一款面料锯纸的
我来量一下
胸围胸围
胸围92
腰围60
可以拉到80
60 80
来群长103
我估计回来要得挨揍
我得打
来这一款谁要29
29扣个7
29扣7
来
好的姐妹们再见了
明天两点不见不散
我下播了